they swept through cities and kingdoms
riding their dead horses hunting with
their packs of pale spiders big as
hounds hey everybody its Charlie you may
have just heard that HBO confirmed
what's going on with the Game of Thrones
prequel just one of them they're getting
ready to film one of the pilots now
there are five that are in development
but we found out what the first one is
going to be and some of you may have
already predicted it but they have a big
plot synopsis which pretty much tells us
exactly what's going on so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos obviously I'll be doing spin-off
videos mostly season 8 stuff dropping
this summer there's a new round of that
4k DVD giveaway they have 4k prints of
the season 1 DVD 2 so just to read the
plot synopsis for the prequel here it
says the series is described as
chronicling the world's descent from the
Golden Age of Heroes into its darkest
hour and only one thing is for sure from
the horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history - the origin of the White
Walkers the mysteries of the east to the
Starks of legend it's not the story we
think we know so effectively they're
doing the transition from the Age of
Heroes to the first long night like
spiders big as hounds they're actually
doing ice spiders as big as hounds so
this is awesome video of old nan telling
her tale of the long night that tells
you exactly what this series is gonna be
about so I cut that with the flashback
to the origin of the night king because
it basically sounds like we're building
to the origin of the night king on this
series and I'll explain the timeline in
a second but here's that video oh my
sweet summer child what do you know
about fear fear is for the winter when
the snow was falling undred feet deep
fear is for the long night when the Sun
hides for years and children are born
and live and die all in darkness that is
the time for fear my little Lord when
the White Walkers moved through the
woods thousands of years ago there came
a night
lasted a generation Kings froze to death
in their castles same as the Shepherd's
in their huts and women smothered their
babies rather than see them starve and
wept and felt the tears freeze on their
cheeks so is this the sort of story that
you like
in that darkness the White Walkers came
for the first time they swept through
cities and kingdoms riding their dead
horses hunting with their packs of pale
spiders big as hounds I love the way old
man poses that question to bran is that
the kind of story that you want what are
the scary ones
and it becomes super meta because
they're doing that for the prequel but
this is one of the prequels that George
R Martin has been working on himself
with Jane Goldman so she's the other
person that's been developing this and
remember is just one of five but HBO
ordered it to pilot meaning they're
gonna start filming it soon and will
have an idea for what it's gonna look
like and now you know we know Age of
Heroes transitioned along night we know
what the timeline is going to be and
here's sort of the cliff notes on the
timeline of ancient history as per the
TV show in the books so there are a
couple differences in how long ago
things happen so I'll try to explain
within the TV show the three-eyed Raven
says that the long night happened about
a thousand years ago it lasted for what
they call a generation which is like
tens of years less than a hundred years
in the books it's between six and eight
thousand years ago so also coinciding
with that is the rise of the Valyrian
freehold see what they did there so you
know we wanted them to do in ancient
filarial prequel series it sounds like
they're doing that with this because
once you go back past a couple thousand
years time periods get really ambiguous
so like obviously the rise of the
Valyrian freehold wasn't happening at
exactly the same time is the first long
night but it sounds like they'll
compress that on the TV show so you'll
see both of those things happen so in
the way that the main show started off
during season one with all the Starks
and everybody in Westeros and then
Daenerys over in the east you have like
two different continents it sounds like
that's what this prequel show is gonna
bounce back and forth between there are
a lot of myths about how they stopped
the first long night it was a union
between the men and the children of the
forest obviously we know that the
children of the forest created the night
King in the White Walkers but it sounds
like we might get to see a version of
the war with the first men because it
sounds like they're chronicling the
transition into Westeros is darkest
history so I wouldn't call it a long
night series I would call it an age of
hero series this
begins the long night but we all know
the myth of how they ended the long
night we don't know if that's how the
series is going to end or if it's going
to end with the creation of the night
king and it's gonna be like Oh
everybody's screwed like and it'll just
dip to black like The Sopranos or if
it's gonna be more like the main show
which sounds like they defeat the night
king Westeros lays in ruins but they've
averted a second long night because
that's the whole goal of the show right
now obviously it was all about the Iron
Throne for the first couple of seasons
but now it's about stopping the second
long night so obviously we know the
first long night ended up happening so
that could happen somewhere in the
middle of the series so I think that
we're just gonna try to find a way to do
those events without making it seem like
a retread of the things that we've done
before but have you been following the
production on season 8 they've actually
been building out the King's Landing set
at their Titanic studios they call that
the paint hall because they expect that
they'll be filming some of the scenes at
the prequel series there now obviously
there are five so they're gonna be set
during different time periods but you
can redress certain sets to make them
look like different castles because the
Red Keep and King's Landing
didn't exist during the Age of Heroes
like it was all just divided up into the
seven different kingdoms of Westeros but
because this is the Age of Heroes during
this series we might get to see some of
the people that started some of the
major houses and obviously the night
king is supposed to be a stark of
Winterfell that's still a myth right now
unconfirmed but there's a lot of strong
evidence to support that so we might get
to see his life at Winterfell before he
was turned into the night King but
during the Age of Heroes you have
characters like bran the Builder I know
there are a lot of theories about bran
on the TV show right now being all the
brand's that's like a kind of a separate
thing we can talk about that as we learn
more about the prequels artists Aaron
the person that started house Aaron the
gray King first ruler of the Ironborn
land the clever person who started house
lannister Garth greenhand
first ruler of the reach during God's
grief first ruler of the Stormlands the
timeline for when a lot of those people
were alive is really fuzzy but just
because of the way they can compress
time on the TV show we might meet some
of them on the prequel series the first
high king of Westeros was supposed to be
Garth greenhand but the plot synopsis on
the press release says it's not the
store
we think we know so it sounds like
George our Martin is gonna be providing
a lot of more concrete details about
what actually happened there and giving
them a blueprint for how to plan this
series out remember the story about how
he told Dan and Dave in a special
conversation what his end for Game of
Thrones was and where he was taking the
characters and then obviously they
changed a lot of things from the books
but he gave him a blueprint for where he
was headed so the thing about this
prequel series is that a lot of that
history is nebulous so they're not
stepping on the toes of stuff that
George or Martin is going to be writing
in the future so there's no real threat
of them passing book plot in most of
what we know about that period is all
myth and conjecture it's like other
people like old man telling stories so
just let me know what you think about
this remembering that it's only one of
the five prequels
so obviously the others will take place
during different time periods feature
different characters some of it will
probably cover the fire and blood book
that George R Martin is releasing later
this year leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below
congratulations two dead raise you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for that
season 8 teaser and click here for all
my other season 8 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody to stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight